when you look at the idea of money so
much of it is given by the norms and the
rituals of a society look at America and
when you go out to eat with your friends
how much do you tip when you go to
dinner maybe it's 10 maybe these 15
percent but did you know that if you're
seated outside on a nice sunny day
you're more likely to tip more money
because the Sun puts you in a better
mood but if you seated inside or if it's
an overcast day you may tip less money
so the whole confusion of what of how
much the tip you're not actually the one
making the decision it's your
subconscious that's making that decision
for you and so as you go across the
emerging world and other developed
countries people did tip at different
levels and that line of what the tip
really reveals not just how that much
they value the service but what's
acceptable in terms of the gift economy
what's acceptable in terms of not
tipping too much it reveals a lot about
how people perceive money and
obligations and countries around the
world I know in some places when you
give too big a tip it implies that
you're trying to shame the person is
saying like listen I'm giving you so
much money shame on you for not treating
me better in some Native American
communities for example they have a
practice called a potlatch and you have
a pouch when there was a new king or new
queen or new chief and they would invite
all their friends and then they would
start giving out all their goods all
these riches to their friends it was
called a potlatch and they're basically
shaming people lavishing them with with
riches as it is to say I'm so rich I'm
so affluent I don't even need this money
and so as you go into tipping culture
sometimes the biggest insult you can
give it's too big of a tip